bonsoir messieurs merci d'être en direct
ce soir avec nous sur rt france la
situation est assez confuse aujourd'hui
dans la vallée du panjshir elle aurait
été reprise par les talibans le fils du
commandant massoud qui emmène les
combattants anti taliban démentent si
les faits étaient confirmés est ce que
ce serait une sorte de tournant en
afghanistan que les parcs que les
taliban soient parvenus à reprendre la
vallée du panjshir pierre berthelot
un tournant peut-être pas définitif
puisque en fait cette vallée du panjshir
comme on sait a toujours été un foyer de
résistance
depuis au-moins l'invasion soviétique de
et donc même si elle était reprise est
ce que ce serait réellement durable ce
n'est pas certain d'autant plus que les
talibans risque d'avoir d'autres foyers
de contestation
effectivement à gérer donc c'est
peut-être une avancée mais une avancée
qui sent to hope espoir est relative
quel est votre regard sur ce point
pierre emmanuel thomas n'avait du
panjshir aujourd'hui c'est surtout un
symbole de résistance où elle elle
représente aujourd'hui un vrai poids en
terme de forces vives de combattants de
poids politique de soutien aux 6 de la
population
goûter sur le long terme le temps long
de la géopolitique
l'afghanistan n'a jamais été totalement
unifié il ya toujours eu des tensions
récurrentes en fonction de la géographie
extrêmement compartimenté et les tribus
donc c'est une société tribale et il
faut pas s'attendre à ce que le un état
national afghan unifiée émergent si ça
ne s'est pas produit dans le passé il
restera instable à l'avenir et donc nous
aurons des révoltes qui éclateront
qui éclatent déjà d'ailleurs et qui
éclateront sûrement à l'avenir lorsque
les terribles n'arriveront pas à
satisfaire toute la population même si
son l'ethnie principal qui aujourd'hui
prend le pouvoir on attend la
composition l'annoncent la composition
du nouveau gouvernement taliban dans les
prochaines heures vraisemblablement
demain au plus tôt
c'est une annonce qui sera capital ce
nouveau gouvernement qu'est ce qu'il
représentera à l'échelle nationale et
internationale
pierre berthelot
ce sera effectivement quelque chose qui
va être scrutée avec la plus grande
attention mais encore une fois comme
vous le savez dans tout en toupie
les apparences ne correspond pas souvent
à la réalité c'est à dire qu'on peut
nommer des personnes à des postes etc
mais est ce que réellement elles ont une
marge de manoeuvre est ce que ne sont
pas juste un alibi donc ça c'est ça qui
est important ce qui compte en soit
c'est plutôt le pouvoir corrompt ceux
qui ne sont pas visiblement
talibans est ce que l'objectif de ce
gouvernement comme ils l'ont annoncé
c'est qu'ils soient inclusives
c'est-à-dire qu'ils intègrent des gens
qui ne soient pas des talibans donc si
c'est le cas ça sera une bonne chose
mais encore faut-il savoir
quels seront leurs ma la marge de
manoeuvre de ces personnes qui seront
appelés au gouvernement et puis de qui
s'agit-il précisément s'il s'agit par
exemple de faire entrer les partisans de
boules ou dîner avec mme attias donc qui
est lui aussi un âne islamistes mais
peut-être encore plus radical que les
talibans
donc est ce que réellement pourrait
parler d'un gouvernement inclusif
finalement on ferait rentrer quelqu'un
qui est assez proche de l'idéologie des
talibans envoyez donc il faut voir qu'il
y aura et quels seront leurs marges de
manoeuvre qu'elle soit éventuellement
les ministères qui seront confiées tout
ceci pour le moment reste bien un
certain manuel thomas ne vous dirais que
les talibans aujourd'hui son pense d'une
entreprise de communication lorsqu'il
évoque leur volonté de former un
gouvernement inclusif
bien sûr puisque avec le retrait
américain et de l'otan les occidentaux
ont annoncé qu'ils ne donneraient plus
d' aide aux talibans donc à
l'afghanistan et pour avoir un soutien
international pour ne pas être
totalement isolé il essaye de montrer
qu'ils sont capables de de gérer le pays
de former un gouvernement avec les
différentes
des représentants des différentes tribus
des différents visages de l'afghanistan
mais évidemment c'est c'est une
entreprise difficile de communication
qui va sans doute être temporaires et
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est aussi de
voir quelles seront en termes de
reconnaissance internationale quelles
seront les pays qui arriveront avoir une
influence en afghanistan
parce que celle c'est l'enjeu à mon avis
principal
qui va tirer les ficelles derrière les
ce nouveau gouvernement afghan et on
sait que le retrait du des etats-unis de
l'otan qui est en fait une régression
des frontières de l'euro atlantisme
depuis les attentats du 11 septembre où
l'espace euro atlantique sur domination
américaine voulait étendre leurs zones
d'influencé jusqu en eurasie c'est un
c'est un retrait et une
réduction des frontières de cet espace
et qui laisse plus d'espacé à l'inde la
chine la russie le pakistan et certains
pays d'asie centrale qui sont au bord de
l'afghanistan et on bat ce qui va être
intéressant de voir qui
sont ces liens ce gouvernement afghan
nouveau gouvernement à coups qu'elle n'y
en aura t-il avec les innovations on
revient vers vous dans un instant en
espérant que la liaison soit meilleur
pierre berthelot pour reprendre les
perles
évoqué à l'instant de ces pays qui
pourrait tenir les ficelles de ce
gouvernement que les talibans veulent
inclusif quel rôle peut jouer le qatar
le qatar qui visiblement le principal
interlocuteur aujourd'hui des talibans
pas le cas bien sûr espère jouer un rôle
majeur et de façon
un peu ironique c'était ses principaux
rivaux qui avant était un peu à la
manoeuvre on repense à l'arabie saoudite
notamment qu' on sait déjà très proche
du pakistan qui lui même est accusé
d'être un peu
le mentor des talibans on dit que c'est
une création des services secrets
pakistanais
et donc là effectivement on aurait un
nouvel acteur qui n'existait pas il ya
quelques décennies
donc la question c'est dans quelle
mesure justement les rivaux du qatar ne
vont pas essayer
peut-être de déstabiliser ce nouveau
rôle ça aussi c'est intéressant donc
l'arabie saoudite va t'elle renoncer à
son rôle traditionnel
de partenaire privilégié du pakistan
c'est une question qui se pose est ce
qu'elle va accepter de laisser la place
au qatar c'est pas forcément certains et
donc effectivement on pourra peut-être
observer
des
déchirements en tout cas des situations
complexes parce que peut-être
effectivement derrière il y aura des
pays qui voudront garder leur rôle
traditionnel on a vu quels nouveaux
acteurs parler du qatar on sait que le
qatar est assez proche de la turquie par
exemple donc les turcs aussi peuvent
jouer un rôle ce que monsieur erdogan
ses voeux a des ambitions très
importante pour son pays
donc là aussi ces acteurs comment est-ce
qu'ils vont réussir à manoeuvrer sans
être eux-mêmes contré par d'autres
acteurs qui pouvaient traditionnellement
influent dans la région pour revenir sur
cette influence
à l'égard des talibans pierre-emmanuel
thomann aujourd'hui qui parle aux
insurgés est ce que vous vous avez noté
aussi ces derniers temps un
infléchissement du côté des occidentaux
dans leur attitude vis-à-vis des
talibans
alors ce qui est notable c'est de voir
qu'en fait tout le monde essaye de
parler aux talibans même si tout le
monde les critiques en même temps par
parce que tout le monde se méfie et fait
des hypothèses sur l'avenir
les etats-unis ont négocié leur sortie
de l'afghanistan avec les talibans dont
qu ils ont engagé un dialogue les les
russes essaye de
indiqué qu'ils aimeraient avoir une
influence en afghanistan mais contenir
toute velléité des talibans d'exporter
le terrorisme à l'extérieur de
l'afghanistan la chine aussi le pakistan
évidemment à des liens qui sont toujours
restés très fort avec les talibans y
compris pendant leur pendant la guerre
avec la présence de l'otan donc toutes
les grandes puissances et les puissances
régionales
essais chacune de se positionner pour
leurs intérêts géopolitiques qui sont
différents évidemment et
chacune essaye de
d'avoir un cane un canal de dialogue
avec les talibans pour mettre en avant
leurs intérêts et il va être très
intéressant de voir qui va émerger dans
ce nouveau grand jeu
pour dernier mot avec vos pierre
berthelot on a appris il ya quelques
instants comme chef de la diplomatie
américaine allait se rendre au qatar la
semaine prochaine on le rappelle le
qatar qui discutent de très près avec
les talibans qu'est ce que cette visite
signifie symbolise à vos yeux
encore une fois c'est confirme
l'influencé du qatar
et là aussi ça montre l'administration
byden est plutôt le mieux disposé
vis-à-vis de doha que dali de ryad on
sait que son truck le partenaire
privilégié c'était la vie samedi à
laquelle on pouvait rien refuser presque
désormais on sait que le bail dun n'a
pas le même lien on sait qu'il peut
désormais discuter uniquement avec le
souverain régnant et non pas avec le
prince héritier mbs donc à un certain
nombre d'éléments qui sans montrer que
même si bien sûr les liens sont loin
d'être rompu avec l'arabie saoudite
ce n'est plus le partenaire proche
oriental moyen-orientale numéro un ce
désormais il faut aussi compter
davantage avec le qatar qui offre une
image
beaucoup plus policé par rapport à
l'arabie saoudite
merci beaucoup à tous les deux mais
c'est d'avoir participé à cet échange
pierre berthelot chercheur associé à
libé ce directeur de la revue orient
stratégique et pierre-emmanuel thomann
professeur en géopolitique fondateur
d'euro continent et sur le terran sur le
terrain